when you look at like because we always
hear that I mean you obviously played
not too long ago uh five years ago right
well 2017 was your last year was that
the year you want to ring with the
Warriors right yeah
um
and we hear about you you kind of played
through
a whole era and then kind of you know I
feel like 2013-14 is when the NBA really
started to go heavily towards the three
um but who's somebody who gives you
like when you came into the league
energy like just someone who's tough
someone who's playing right now who you
um
I just like guys to play hard because I
think obviously the game has changed
so much that like the game is continuing
to grow and it's because it's it's more
offensive you know what I mean like you
know 78 to 82. I mean the Thunder put up
150 last night against the Celtics I
mean these low defensive grinding games
they used to get don't sell you know
people when they want they they turn on
TV or they watch it on their phone they
want to see dunks they want to see
threes from Heaven can you imagine if
the Spurs and pistons were in the finals
in 2021 people would kill themselves it
wouldn't work so I say all that to say
there's like a it's kind of like the
guys that played like me are kind of
like The Last of a Dying Breed you know
I mean the three and d uh someone in
four surge tough you know glue guys uh
you know guys like Pat Bev guys like uh
PJ Tucker Oh PJ yeah um I mean [ __ ] we
talk about Jay Crowder Crowder you know
Jay Crowders in the in a similar role
like great guy like great locker room
guy great guy OG vet
um so this the game kind of has has
changed so I mean but to me I'm not one
of those guys God man they don't play
defense no like I appreciate what it is
you know I mean like these [ __ ] kids
are so talented man these kids are super
skilled talented athletic as can be and
they're just you know they're they're in
their way they're taking games to the
new level so I love it when I always
because I I'm I mean I grew up a Jordan
fan
um
I obviously was a Suns fan but I put my
I loved Jordan more than I love the sons
as a kid but um I am kind of on the
LeBron side of the goat convo I'm not
mad at that and that's just because I
look at who he played in the finals I I
feel like he went up against the
Warriors all those years he went up
against the dynasty of the Spurs
through Detroit he had to go through
Detroit who just won a ring to get to
the finals Austin
he had to go through Boston I think I
think we also got to think about like
you know
who he was who he had on that Cavaliers
team in o5 when when they went to the
Rosetto seven it was also was it 0705
when they went to the finals it was
against the Spurs but um you know I
think that like
he went went through the Thunder with
Katie Russ and James Harden I'm not mad
I to me I just think that the League's
talent pool is so much more higher than
it was when Jordan and of course Jordan
had to go through the Pistons and and
you know there was Larry Bird and Magic
Johnson and those guys but I just think
the talent pool like I I love watching
every team right now I have League Pass
there's not a team that I'm not
interested in because I got a couple
guys that can go yeah I'm like oh the
Pistons are on well Kate Cunningham's
out but I'm like oh I want to see Ivy I
want to see uh uh uh Bae like there's
like uh no I definitely get it and when
I was a kid like the Clippers like
sucked like they really sucked but even
the teams that aren't good are still fun
to watch and have good right now it's
crazy it's crazy yeah
what was the question though no I was
gonna say like do you feel like the
talent because you you played through so
many like 15 years do you feel like the
talent pool nowadays is just off the
charts deeper than it's ever been or is
that just recency bias because we're
watching basketball
um
I think the
I think the skill level might be as high
as we've ever seen it uh Talent you know
you think back to the you know late 80s
early 90s and then I don't even want to
disrespect nowhere because every year I
had talent but yeah I'm thinking like
you know young Mike in that in that era
there there was there was a lot of
[ __ ] in that era but I think
often you know we just we're kind of
prisoners of of now and and what we've
seen of like you know I mean so
obviously there's a lot of Talent on on
on on both sides but I just feel like
the skill level the athleticism the
athleticism all this [ __ ] is just it's
it's it's it continues to grow I think
like back in the day like the Cavaliers
were like a big deal for the Bulls to go
against with Craig Elo and Brad Daughtry
yeah or whatever the [ __ ] his name was I
used to play with him on NBA Jam when I
was a kid
um but I'm like none of the like none of
like nobody's gonna be like both of
those guys are all-time greats nobody's
saying I mean they were good at the time
right but I think now and I'm just like
yo like if you look at all three of the
all NBA teams every year it's like [ __ ]
like the fact like KD can get left off
because he was injured you know it's
just like
the fact Damian Lillard is like not in
the top 10 right now I think the game
has just continued to evolve yeah it's
crazy because Damien was like an
all-time great point guard no question
but back to my original point like I
don't any like to me it's it's it's MJ
and there's no odor but in these three I
can give with Arguments for either of
them MJ Kobe and and Mike right as far
as to me those are the well you said MJ
Kobe and Mike
excuse me MJ Cove and LeBron like to me
I can see Jordan being one I could see
some people have code number one some
people have LeBron number one you know I
could see to me those three guys are
at with all due respect everyone else at
the top of the pyramid
um you know you hear guys like you know
and you never want to disrespect Legends
or or people that come before you but I
just feel like some of those older older
players like when you talk about the top
75 of those older players that were like
foundational for the league and and yeah
like almost like their meat the meaning
to the league outweighs their actual
talent yeah I mean to me like there's no
way you can leave a Dwight Howard or
Vince Carter or Tracy
immigration's crazy for sure he was the
most he was the best center for 10 years
yeah so it's just like there's so much
stuff that you know to me because like
you said the talent level is so much on
a night-to-night basis uh better than it
was you know back in the 50s 60s you
know coming into the 70s it's just like
a lot of these current guys that got
left off you look at it just like no
those guys really weren't better than
these guys that left I wasn't close